As Eames said,
the details make the design.
Motion can be an opportunity
to provide delight and
make a connection with your user.
They can also bring
personality to your app.
After all, animating literally
means bringing to life.
Whenever an element changes state
this is a great opportunity to
animate this change.
This helps both to explain what is
changing and can direct attention.
This technique isn't restricted
to larger blocks of your UI.
Animating small details
eases the transition.
Take a look at these examples.
The clock up here runs an animation
whenever we switch tab.
This helps to communicate
the tab's purpose.
PocketCasts here animates the transition
between the play and pause states.
And here the Google I/O app, when we
reach the bottom, it animates the logo.
Now these last two might not
provide extra functionality.
These small details bring
a smile to your face and
make the experience of using
the app more enjoyable.